>> Greg: SAN FRANCISCO
CONTINUES TO BECOME THE
HUMAN POOP CAPITAL OF THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE.
WHAT IS THEIR MAYOR
CONCERNED WITH.
E-CIGS?
HE SIGNED AN ORDINANCE
BANNING
BANVANG
BANVAPING SALES.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO VAPE TO
SEE HOW IDIOTIC THIS IS LET
ME OFFER A PLUG.
VAPEING GOT ME TO QUIT
SMOKING FAR MORE HARMFUL.
IF VAPING HAD BEEN AROUND 30
YEARS AGO SO WOULD A LOT 6
YOUR RELATIVES.
I DON'T VAPE ANYMORE BUT IT
HELPED GET ME HERE.
THE MAYOR SAYS THERE IS MUCH
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THESE
PRODUCTS BUT YOU COULD HAVE
SAID THE SAME THING ABOUT
WIND FARMS OR CELL PHONES
BUT NO, SHE MEANS VAPING.
SO VAPING IS THE HEALTH
HAZARD IN HER CITY.
INJECTING HEROIN ON THE
STREETS NEAR A SCHOOL.
I GUESS WHEN YOU CAN'T
ADDRESS YOUR CITY'S BIG
PROBLEMS, YOU LOOK TO VAPING
AS A DISTRACTION FROM
FAILURE.
AND WHAT'S IS A MONUMENTAL
FAILURE DYSTOPIAN OPEN SEWER
SUPER RICH SIGNAL FROM BO
AND HOMELESS RELIEVE
THEMSELVES BELOW.
IT'S CLEAR YOU CAN ACCEPT
ANY KIND OF MS. RID IF YOU
ARE WELL ENOUGH AWAY FROM
IT.
SO THE RISE IN BANNING
THINGS WILL CONTINUE UNLESS,
OF COURSE, THE HOMELESS DO
IT OR ANTIFA DOES IT OR
UNDOCUMENTED ALIENS DO IT
THEN BREAKING LAWS IS SIMPLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO
BECAUSE ANYTHING ELSE WOULD